ufc south can we talk oh yeah what's up  what the [ __ ] is wrong with you what did  we do oh you know nothing major just  your division came out of week one with  zero wins despite playing the giants the  commanders and each other you know how  hard that is really not that hard it's  hard okay you're acting like we weren't  even trying no you guys were trying you  just stunk so much for that quarterback  upgrade yeah carson's not that bad but  in overtime they decided it was too much  effort to try and win so they punted  from midfield with 30 seconds left it  was a calculated decision you straight  up surrendered and accepted the tie who  made that play call robert e lee okay  just one of you get a win next week all  right who do you all play the bills okay  so not you broncos also not great we  play each other oh perfect uh if you  guys tie i'm relocating one of you to  london and the other to mexico we're  destined for london anyway